welcome back AI systems can make music
generate art mimic photography and right
somehow you can augment human Ingenuity
enabling artists to explore novel
Avenues and collaborate with AI in
innovative ways but it could clearly
impact cultural jobs others fear risks
to total loss of human creativity and in
bad news for TV writers everything I
just said was scripted by AI but is also
being used in the entertainment industry
to bring beloved singers and movie
characters back to life America's Got
Talent the show I used to work on also
got a taste of just what AI can do when
Simon Cowell Harry Mandel and Terry
Crews stood to the stage or at least
their AI replicas did
look like an angel
Devil in Disguise
[Applause]
[Music]
well I'm not joined by the comedian star
of NBC's America's Got Talent Harry
Mandel and legendary actor William
Shatner welcome to both of you so Howie
um I mean I knew it was a fake the
moment I heard you sing because you
can't sing so but was it a weird
experience seeing that and what do you
think of AI where's your mind with all
this
amazing I am so up on technology I love
it I think we got to embrace it I I've
been listening to your show from the
beginning uh people uh screaming fire in
the building I I think number one nobody
and there is no uh choice in stopping it
there's no way you're going to stop it
Embrace technology I always have I I
embrace AI I embrace Holograms I've
invested in a hologram company which is
actually in the O2 right there
proto-hologram and that's because I can
be in two places at once I would love to
somebody to write for me I would like to
I've actually licensed my AI image to a
Korean company because I want to be able
to be places and do things without being
there makes me much more productive it
makes the world productive you know
nobody stopped the automobile even
though all the blacksmiths seem to have
lost their job you know we'll just find
new things to do okay but how would you
feel how would you feel artistically if
if an AI robot was able to write all
your jokes for you and you literally had
no input would you care
as long as you pay me but the truth is
what you're saying doesn't really exist
you know we need the human Ingenuity or
creativity to prompt AI we need to come
up with the ideas of what we want AI to
do you're not going to stop this
technology we didn't stop the world wide
web and you know people are putting
things out there and we could generate I
don't know if you're on Instagram but a
lot of people are a lot better looking
than they actually are it enhances yes
there are naysayers that uh that say bad
things will happen but bad things happen
with cars bad things happen with all
technology bad things happen just when
people are left to their own this is all
good people you know what if bad things
used to happen AI a golden buzzer yeah I
mean bad things used to happen to me
when I work with you quite regularly
normally because of you
um let me go to William shakes I miss
you buddy look at the William Shatner
William you celebrating your 90th
birthday recently by creating an AI
powered version of yourself that will
live forever which I was thrilled to
hear about but does that mean you're all
over this too the AI phenomenon are you
embracing it with great Glee are you are
you worried I I too have been listening
to your program from the beginning of
what I'm missing and what I think
is uh possibly promising is morality how
do you teach a computer morality which
brings us back to human beings how do
you teach morality to human beings will
it be possible to teach these artificial
intelligence entities as they become
more and more sophisticated morality and
so they cannot be able to do bad things
to harm people
uh then you get into the question of
authentication can you authenticate an
image so that there's no question that
it's an imitation or it's the real thing
you're there are areas that are
sophisticated that can help uh take care
of the things that we've heard on this
program that are very real taking will a
uh will a uh uh a a uh artificial
intelligence become sentient
will it feel endorphins and and will it
feel good when it does something good
and feel bad when it does something bad
if it could be taught to do that I mean
the thing is most of the areas the thing
is with him I mean you can teach look
you can teach a dog you can teach a
child you can teach them to about
morality and they'll pick it up and
learn it the thing about AI presumably
you ask about morality if you feed
enough information into AI about
morality and what is moral and what is
right and what is wrong why wouldn't it
be even better than any child
assimilating that information that's
exactly what I'm saying that's exactly
what I'm saying built internally into
every AI is a morality but then how do
you teach morality because morality
differs from and how do you stop it how
do you stop it conversely how do you
stop it being immoral how do you stop a
nefarious actor getting hold of it
exactly Insanity from doing that
say that again Harry well you can't stop
how do you stop Humanity so that's why
when you get all over excited about and
say how brilliant this all is I am
genuinely worried simply because history
tells us that yes every great new
innovation is great but in the hands of
Bad actors this is including the
internet for example bad things can
happen and I'm not sure how you stop it
welcome to the world disappears this is
I've talked about my own
I got
well
everybody thought it was a bad thing the
first time I purchased an inflatable sex
doll but now my wife has so much more
time to watch her TV show
okay William on the bad stuff I mean I
totally agree with you if you can turn
AI moral great if it can be turned
equally easily to be immoral what do we
do about that
our artificial intelligence is merely an
extension at the moment of humanity and
Humanity carries with it uh the great
goodness of the web telescope and the uh
horror of the Ukraine war we carry that
capacity within us the our machines that
help us will have the same capacity how
do we regulate that how do we
authenticate that those are problems
that need to be solved and are soluble
but we can't ignore them what is for you
Howie the most exciting thing about AI
what are you most looking forward to
being able to do with it
productivity to be in more than one
place and do more than one thing more
than I as a human have the capacity to
do you know and um I've invested in
companies like protohologram and AI
companies to be to be bigger and more
productive than I actually am yeah and
you know listen what we have in the
capacity that I have as a human being is
finite is short is is is in a box and
now I can think outside that box and I
can be in multiple locations at once and
it may not even be me and I'm okay with
that as long as I get some credit for
whatever was created and William very
quickly for you the most exciting idea
about AI that you've had
I just read this morning AI is starting
to invent a antibiotic that uh is will
take care of the superbugs that's just
the beginning of the steps that AI can
help us with